I'm current Davina today we're talking
about World of Warcraft also Nathan
Drake actor himself has some thoughts on
the upcoming uncharted movie and the
dark pictures a little hope gets a
release date this is a safe state
GameSpot's
big old news show for Wednesday July 8th
welcome the uncharted movie that's
supposedly happening is gonna be
focusing on a young Nathan Drake played
by young spider-man boy himself Tom
Holland but Nolan North the actor who
plays Nathan Drake in the games says the
Chris Pine would have been a great
choice for an adult a Drake
that is if that's the story the movie
was trying to tell speaking to fandom
Nolan said quote I got to watch Chris
Pine work and I sat with him at lunch
one time the makeup trailer I said if a
script called Uncharted ever comes
across your agents desk you should take
a good hard look at it because I think
you'd be perfect for it Nolan also feels
that the movie it shouldn't be a
one-to-one adaptation of the games and
well it isn't because young not young
Drake we haven't we've seen like bits of
young Drake in the games but this is
like Tom Holland Drake
uncharted is a movie already if they
were doing a one to one Chris Pine is I
think he's got the everyman quality
charm humor I really liked working with
him he's a good solid actor and a good
guy that would be my top choice now I
know you're all dying to know who I
think would make the best Nathan Drake
and clearly it'd be Nathan Drake himself
Nolan North either that or Danny DeVito
maybe Rowan Atkinson flip a coin well
any of those three would just be would
be perfect the movie is still scheduled
for July 2021 but given things are and
Co vid and all that jazz it's assumable
it might be delayed not that that it
hasn't been delayed already many many
times so it's leaked we'll see
speaking of delay is due to Cove it the
next installment and the dark pictures
anthology little hope is getting pushed
back to drumroll October 30th with the
announcement of the delay we did at
least get some new additions that are
gonna be available
to pre-order in fact you can check out
some of the info on GameSpot's very own
pre-order guide so we're gonna have a
standard edition we're gonna have a
collector's edition with some physical
goodies then there's also a volume one
edition that includes little hope in the
previous game man of Madden plus all the
stuff from the collector's edition
preorder any version to get early access
to the curators cut which includes some
bonus scenes with additional story
choices for the characters to make the
curators cut will be available for
everyone for free a few months after
little hope comes out but pre-ordering
gets it ahead of time also some bonus
content right here for you
I interviewed will poulter about this
game and his differences with acting on
film and games he also plays three roles
in it which is pretty sweet there'll be
a link to that interview in the
description below
world of warcraft got a big old
expansion on the wake hold shadow lands
and it's all about the covenants and we
got loads of details today during its
live summit the focus is around four
covenants they have their own story
quests each has its own soul binds which
is basically a unique skill tree they
also have their own private areas called
sanctums and as to be expected that's
gonna have a new dungeon area and raids
Peter pain is a nonlinear dungeon where
you can choose which parts to explore
first with boss fights against champions
from each of the covenants the MA is a
sandbox area where you're not welcome
and there's Castle nuria which is gonna
be a ten boss raid and the beta is gonna
kick off next week now interestingly the
new level cap is sixty so if you're the
current max level cap at 120 you're
gonna be squished down to 50
it's slated to come out sometime this
year and be on the lookout because we're
gonna have some content on it coming up
hey did you know that play pearls
happening it's a thing we've been doing
and talking about and it's great and you
should still be aware that it's
happening in fact my cat Lilly has
joined me once again to share the news
play for all is a multi week event every
single day with streams from 12 p.m. to
2 p.m. Pt featuring loads a special
guest to raise money for both black
lives matter and Coppa 19 relief
accompanying these interviews is a bunch
of exclusive content stuff like the
interview with will poulter so be on the
lookout for more that's coming in the
description below also GameSpot now has
its own official merge story and all the
proceeds till the end of August is going
to black lives matter in kovin 19 relief
it's got speed stuff like t-shirts and a
face mask and a skateboard there's some
of us drawn on it I'm on it
my hair's my hair's a little lighter
than it is but that's me I promise
alright that's it you could find out
about that everything I've talked about
today and a whole lot more by going to
gamespot.com I'm Kurt and Davina thanks
for joining me be well wash your hands
pet a cat if you got one dream about it
I don't know do ever you want alright
see you later
you